will you there
yeah how's it going pop i'm doing all
right how are you buddy
i'm good i'm good i'm good all right
let's run let's run through this real
quick we got a couple of charts we're
gonna pull up here the first one is the
on-chain cost basis uh explain to us
what's uh what's going on with the
on-chain cost basis i don't think a lot
of people know what this is yeah so what
we're looking at here is just the
average cost basis or the average price
that uh short-term holders have bought
in or another way to look at this for
technical traders is this is an on-chain
v-wap or volume weighted average price
yeah and so essentially this is kind of
served as like this bull market support
band if you will from an on-chain
perspective uh yeah so if you see 2017
this is kind of served as support uh
once we broke below that then you know
we've we've turned into kind of a you
know we headed back into the bear market
uh got rejected off of that you know had
a failed underside reached us to that
like four times once we broke back below
that kind of marked the end of the of
the bear market um as you can see this
also served as support uh once we got
back above you know after the march uh
you know coveted capitulation in in
september of last year served as support
uh broke below heading into may got back
above it at the beginning of september
and then got confirmation at the end of
september
but now we're kind of sitting right on
that band that currently sits at 53k
which also aligns with technical support
uh as well as the kind of one trillion
dollar market cap threshold um and so
the the way i kind of see this is
currently you know when you look at some
of these broader on-chain dynamics that
are saying we're still in the bull
market um with that in mind if you do
think that's the case then the the
asymmetry is pretty heavily skewed to
the upside here because we're close to
that what what has traditionally been
kind of this bull market support band
and so the way i'm kind of looking at
the market is in the first chart you'll
see some of the derivative stuff um i
think in the short term like i would
definitely wouldn't rule out any kind of
you know liquidation driven flush or
wick down
just because we haven't really seen any
flush and open interest as well as
funding and we haven't really seen any
like sizable amounts of liquidations
which usually kind of mark bottoms for
bitcoin um and so you know i wouldn't i
wouldn't rule that out by any means but
as long as we're as long as we're
closing and keyword is closing above uh
53k i don't i don't see any you know
anything to be getting necessarily
panicked about um i think we're you know
right along that kind of bull market
support band area currently and you know
based off of some of these other
on-chain dynamics um you know i i still
do think we're in this you know broader
kind of bull trend um you know i think
this this code variant news or whatever
obviously wasn't wasn't great for the
bitcoin market as well as
legacy markets but you know when i'm
looking at kind of these these dynamics
that we've we've been tracking you know
that are we're looking to play out over
the coming months etc like i don't i
don't see anything that's necessarily
changed in those things if they do you
know i'll change my outlook but yeah on
the shorter term time frames you know
right along that kind of bull market
sport band as well as when we look at
soper uh we got a nice bounce off of
soaper as well
i mean the only the the bare case i
would say in the short term is just kind
of from the derivative stuff in the
sense that we haven't really seen a real
flush out yet which usually we do see
kind of at these bottoms got it okay and
then we've got the entity adjusted sopra
it looks like it bounced pretty hard off
of uh one there
yeah we bounced off one uh as we talked
about before this one is where kind of
the profit and loss balance each other
out that's being realized on every given
day so when you're above one you're in a
state of profit when you're below you're
in a state of loss so what you want to
see in kind of these broader bullish
trends is to come back down to that one
threshold and retest it we've been
talking for about a month now about kind
of how it's had started to kind of roll
over and we were suspecting that we'd
probably come back down get that retest
which we actually have gotten over the
last couple days and so um seeing that
bounce is obviously a good sign
you know i think the kind of
invalidation for me
would be seeing soaper go below one as
well as kind of having this failed
underside retest if we if we were to go
below it in addition to um you know
starting to see a liquid supply roll
over and then as we just looked at the
on-chain cost basis
going below that and also failing to to
break back above that and that's what
happened at the end of 2017 we broke
below but then couldn't get back above
we got rejected off of that whereas
after coming out of the summer we did
get back above so
you know looking for a couple of those
things is kind of my invalidation if you
will um but you know aside with with the
shortest like short term stuff aside um
none of the kind of macro cyclical
behavior that you know we've been
tracking has has changed over the last
couple days
and you know if you're i didn't throw
any of that stuff in the newsletter this
week just because it was a bit shorter
shorter than usual because thanksgiving
i kind of threw it together this morning
but um you know check out some of the
stuff in that thread that i have pinned
on my twitter and there's like 20 22
different metrics that you can look at
for that last chart i want to go over
and then i know that we've uh we've got
to let you go is the supply shock ratios
uh you've highlighted here with kind of
the bullish divergence um talk to us a
little bit about what the supply shock
ratio is showing us and then what these
uh mean yeah this is the metric i
created with lily back over the summer
you're essentially comparing the weak to
strong hands so you're looking at the
liquid and highly liquid entities and
burning a ratio of those to the illiquid
entities and so what we see is whenever
we have these kind of dislocations
between the metric and price it resolves
in the in the direction of the metric so
if you see you know back in the back in
september of last year we had this move
up in price meanwhile we had you know a
drawdown in the ratio so we had a
bearish divergence where the oscillator
is going one way price is going the
opposite that resolved to the downside
in price um and then conversely after
that you know we had a price draw down
as well as the ratio starting to tick up
and then that resolved to the upside
i had a couple of these bull divs
earlier this year in january there was a
pretty substantial one as well as a
minor one in march uh heading into kind
of this this you know mini bear over the
over the summer we had a pretty strong
bear divergence between the oscillator
as well as price because you started to
see supply becoming liquid and kind of
the weeks leading up to that drawdown
saw the same thing at the end of 2017
you saw supply becoming liquid in the
weeks before that drawdown yeah and so
since then saw a bullish divergence
which pomp i remember very vividly yes
talking about on here over the summer
oscillator was grinding up meanwhile
price was grinding down another bull div
at the end of september earlier this
year when we came back and retested 40k
oscillator was grinding up price was
grinding down that resolved in the
direction of the oscillator moving up
and just recently over the last couple
weeks uh we have again a very strong uh
bullish divergence between the
oscillator has been ticking up pretty
heavily meanwhile price has been moving
down pretty heavily so
i'm personally expecting that to resolve
in the direction of the oscillator given
that it doesn't start to roll over
because that's just what's happened uh
historically as as we've seen and
especially over the summer we saw
sometimes it can take you know several
weeks to kind of you know resolve itself
but
going back in bitcoin's history it's
hard to kind of find a time where that
hasn't really resolved in the direction
of the oscillator
got it uh real quick before you go just
general sentiment you still feel pretty
good even though prices drawn down
yeah i mean i think as long as we have
these kind of uh clear kind of
invalidation points that we talked about
a couple minutes ago uh you know the
broader sense i think we see higher
bitcoin prices over the next couple
months you know i think whenever legacy
markets have a substantial drawdown
you're gonna see that in the bitcoin
market as well um and you know i do
think there's there's a fair you know
case to say that we probably have a
another kind of flush down given some of
the derivative stuff we looked at but
you know we talk about you know kind of
the broader picture for you know more
long-term holders i don't think
necessarily that you know we're heading
into any kind of multi-year bear market
given where the data stands now you know
data changes i'll change my mind
you're the man
will the wizard i appreciate you jumping
on very quickly i know that uh during
the holidays it's hard uh oh look at
look you're getting a little golf clap
from two geniuses over here
we got you will well by the way we're
gonna hit 500 000 followers he's been
what are you at 430 now uh something
like that yeah bag it put it i told you
book it he's never hitting 500k before
the end of the year uh listen i
appreciate you so much doing this uh
have a great rest of uh thanksgiving
week but i got one question tell your
family i say hi good uh will who was a
better host me or him
i don't know man john gave me a good run
for you let's get it
i appreciate you watching
i appreciate that answer appreciate that
answer how much you bitcoin you have to
send them this i said i'm nothing for
that answer
appreciate you will i will thank you all
right guys i gotta jet you guys take it
easy thanks for having me on all right
later